news voice is the world's first mobile
app that helps you track
where your news is coming from news
voice helps you track what corporate
interests might be influencing the
narratives in the news you read every
day
arm yourself against corporate media
monopolies by downloading the news voice
app
for free using the link right underneath
this video
so at this point i i think i have to say
something about the situation with
g-lane maxwell in particular because
this came up at donald trump's tuesday
coronavirus press briefing
and trump again was just caught in
another
apparent lie to the point where
i'm increasingly convinced that trump is
scared of what g lane maxwell
may reveal anthony scaramucci believes
that that's exactly what's going on
and so we're we're going to go through
it so just to reset jeffrey epstein was
arrested and charged
with multiple counts of sex trafficking
and assaulting young girls
this this video will now be demonetized
because i mentioned his name
unfortunately but we've got to talk
about this
this has been known for a long time
there's documentaries now about jeffrey
epstein it's been widely explored
documented he was ultimately
found dead in his jail cell of a
reported suicide
his girlfriend maybe ex-girlfriend
whatever
alleged groomer and trafficker of women
and girls
jelaine maxwell who was out of the
public eye for some time
but has since been arrested a few weeks
ago
now there are widespread pictures from
the last 20 plus years
uh and videos of donald trump together
with
jeffrey epstein and elaine maxwell
including with melania trump without
melania trump over the years
there's video we once looked at of trump
and epstein
at a party i believe it was in the late
90s uh trump and epstein together sort
of watching and discussing different
young women who were dancing in front of
them might have been the early 2000s
the point is widespread connections
between trump and epstein now donald
trump was asked about maxwell
on tuesday and trump wished her well
which is a really weird thing to say
about an alleged sex trafficker given
the number of alleged victims
but trump also mentioned something about
prince andrew
uh which you may find interesting so
let's take a look at that clip
just lane maxwell is in prison and a lot
of people want to know
if she's going to turn in powerful
people and i know you've talked in the
past about prince andrew
and uh you criticized bill clinton's
behavior i'm wondering
do you feel that she's going to turn in
powerful men how do you see that working
out
i don't know i haven't really been
following it too much i just wish her
well
frankly i've met her numerous times over
the years especially since i lived in
palm beach and
i guess they lived in palm beach but i
wish her well
whatever it is i don't know the
situation with prince andrew
just don't know not aware of it so a lot
of people are focusing on
trump saying he wishes her well arguably
a wild thing to say given that jilane
maxwell is accused of grooming and
trafficking in young girls and has left
so many alleged victims in her wake
but the thing about and we're going to
talk about wishing her well in a moment
but the thing about prince andrew is
particularly interesting because once
again trump claims total ignorance
prince andrew and epstein i don't know
anything about that
but we have video check out this video
from february
of 2015. this is when donald trump was
getting ready to run for president in
this clip
he says he's about 80 percent certain
he's going to run for president
and it sure seemed like trump knew a lot
about jeffrey epstein
and prince andrew in this clip take a
look you raised the question of jeffrey
epstein in your remarks about
in the q and a i think he's got a
problem i don't think the problem will
be i i don't know but that island was
really a cesspool there's no question
about it just ask prince andrew
he'll tell you about it uh the island
was an absolute cesspool
so friends are friends and he's been
there for many times well i can't say
friends but i know you're friendly you
know them
they play at my clubs a lot i have clubs
and everybody likes to play are you
saying
trump knows about the island and he says
prince
andrew specifically is the guy you want
to talk to
and he even kind of gives a weird kind
of knowing look to one of the
people sitting at that desk on camera
says prince andrew
can tell you about it so clearly in 2015
trump
did think and know about a connection
between epstein
and prince andrew so there's a couple
possibilities here and of course none of
them are good
uh one is trump is lying now trump lies
all the time this is what a lot of
people suspect
and the idea is trump has been
intimately involved with jeffrey epstein
and he knows all about prince andrew and
now he's lying and saying i don't know
anything about prince andrew but
remember
there's a 13 year old girl then 13 year
old girl
who at one point accused trump and
epstein of raping her in epstein's
manhattan condo that suit was since
dropped the other possibility
is again one of trump's cognitive
decline and you might have noticed that
in the 2015 clip i played for you trump
is
obviously more articulate more together
than he is now
it's possible trump has just lost all
memory and he has no recollection of
knowing about the epstein-prince andrew
connection
there have been allegations that say
trump regularly forgets things that
happened five days ago
forgets things all the time so either
trump is a liar
and he knows everything that there is to
know or much of what there is to know
about prince andrew and epstein
or he's lost his memory neither inspires
a lot of confidence now i want to get to
one other component of this
and that's what i'm going to talk about
next and that's the idea
that when trump says i wish her well
about gilain maxwell you hear that i
hear that it sounds weird why would he
wish well
to an alleged child sex trafficker
anthony scaramucci says that's
code from trump to gelane maxwell
to shut up and not say a word about
donald trump so let's talk about that
next